[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in matt miller
maybe we don't need you matt did we just
steal all your draft thunder for next
year
yeah i think so mclovin's got it i mean
you might want to keep him give him a
race
espn's gonna try to give him my job with
all that dark horse quarterback come on
okay over under five quarterbacks taken
in the first round next year are you
going over
under uh i think that's right on the
money uh i will say this
i have 14 quarterbacks rated already for
next year 14 legitimate quarterbacks
not to mention the two that i now have
to add to my list thanks to andrew
14 quarterbacks a lot more than they
were in last year's class i mean we
see eight drafted so i i wouldn't be
surprised if we see more quarterbacks
drafted but
we haven't seen six in the first round
yet so maybe next year's the year but
there's not that clear-cut
trevor lawrence type guy headed into the
year it'll be a lot of players who have
to
develop and ascend whether that's you
know sam howell
north carolina after losing his top two
receivers and top two running backs
keaton slovis has a ton of playmakers
around him his offensive line is going
to be a little bit young but there's
not that established big name right now
all right
run down some of the other quarterbacks
here at least we can keep an eye on this
upcoming season
well i don't want to inflate your ego
too much here dan but you
hit the nail on the head with carson
strong that's my dude for next year
and i thought he was going to be the guy
where i would get to come in here in
like
august and puff my chest up this is the
nevada quarterback
yeah he's he's good though six foot four
220 he's got a a huge arm he can do
enough off platform
i hate comparing players when they have
the same name it feels lazy
but when you watch him you see a lot of
carson wins like he's a big quarterback
with a big arm and good mobility so
i would not be surprised if he ends up
the number one quarterback next year
spencer rattler has been in oklahoma it
feels like forever but he's actually
just a third year player
if you're looking for this year's kyler
murray or zack wilson the undersized
quarterback who's just gonna
run around in the pocket and make crazy
things happen i think spencer rattler is
one of those players malik willis at
liberty
is another uh who mclovin mentioned he's
malik willis 6-1-210
he is an electric athlete probably has
the strongest arm in next year's class
but then they're
kind of your traditional power sam
howell at north carolina phil jerkovich
who transferred from
notre dame to boston college and looks
like he will be an nfl level quarterback
so
plenty of guys to fall in love with
between now and labor day when we kick
this thing back off
looking back on the draft which team
changed the most
with the nfl draft i think carolina
and you have to include the sam darnold
trade in there so they've got a new
quarterback
they added a very good coroner and jc
horn in the first round they got teres
marshall jr
wide receiver in the second round brady
christian sent a tackle in the third
then i thought they really cleaned up on
day three chuba hubbard will play
we we know christian mccaffrey is going
to move around he got hurt last year
mike davis had to step in a lot
i think davion nixon the d tackle from
iowa he's gonna play
and they drafted a long snapper thomas
fletcher from alabama so we know he's
gonna play
i mean they got six or seven
contributors in this first draft for
scott fitter
but i always look at strategy i don't
necessarily look at the player
it's like the raiders with taking uh
alex leatherwood
like where you took him it's not him as
much as where you took him
you know the steelers taking naji harris
okay
did you need to take him there uh you
know carolina decided not to take justin
fields or mac jones you know that they
were going to go with sam darnold who
if he plays well is going to cost him an
awful lot like did you understand
whose strategy did you question and
whose strategy did you praise
i mean my job is to question everyone's
strategy almost right i mean
we can even start with san francisco or
hell we could start with the new york
jets and be like
you know is zach wilson going to be
better than sam darnold did you give
enough framework of structure around him
that that's actually going to work
historically new york jets quarterbacks
don't pan out so if you want to bet on
who's going to bust you just play the
odds and take the jets quarterback but
you know the niners gave up a historical
amount of draft capital
uh the researchers at espn told me that
is the most the team has given up for a
quarterback
since washington traded up for rg3 we
know how that worked with the shanahan's
so
that's a lot of draft capital to give up
and then i thought after trailing san
francisco
reached for aaron banks who's a good
player they reached for ambry thomas in
the third round
i don't know anyone who had a third
round grade on him and they traded up to
take a running back who's been a hurt
every time he's touched the football
basically and trey sermon then they
drafted another running back and elijah
mitchell so
for all of the like we get stars in our
eyes when we think about john lynch and
kyle shanahan they've had one winning
season
and i think outside of trey lance who i
loved that was a very questionable draft
for them and that's something that
remember this team drafted cj beathard
in the third round joe williams in the
third round after he had basically
retired at utah
and so they have not done a great job
outside of george kittle
with their mid-round picks which is
where you have to build your team so i
think
you can question their strategy i liked
washington's strategy to be honest to
not take a quarterback at night or not
to trade up from 19 to get a quarterback
to give up a future first round pick
where next year's draft looks to be
a lot deeper there's going to be a lot
more information so teams like the
giants
the eagles the eagles will have three
first round picks next year the giants
will have two the dolphins will have two
those teams are loaded for next year
where the draft looks deeper
you're gonna have a full college
football season we're gonna be able to
go into schools
we're gonna have a combine so i would
have rather had more picks for 2022 and
less for 2021.
let me propose this to you and i'm
wondering if i could
uh have an honest answer out of kyle
shanahan
if i said prior to making the deal with
the dolphins
keep those draft picks and you can trade
for aaron rodgers
that's what i've been saying that's i've
i've been sent
to anyone who will listen to me you had
to have done your due diligence before
thursday
which is when everyone's saying that
that call took place
uh i was standing with adam schefter
when he broke the news
and it does not sound like this is
something that just happened thursday
morning and adam decided to break it it
sounds like this has been an
ongoing situation you know everyone who
benefits though
why would somebody leak this chef de
said it's not
rogers it's not the packers so i don't
know who benefits why
would you leak this no why
right i mean i think you lick it day of
the draft because you're hoping someone
will make that phone call and the
pressure of the deadline will cause some
action but i to your point dan
san francisco should have been calling
every day
if you could have had aaron rodgers for
three first round picks
you have to do it he's a norcal guy he
wanted to be drafted by your
organization originally
and my conspiracy theory was that's
where he would end up
after the 2021 season so that got blown
to bits but
i do think that yes you should have been
calling and a lot of other teams should
have as well
i mean obviously the chicago bears
they're the packers are not going to
trade aaron rodgers there but
every other team maybe outside of kansas
city
the chargers and the bills
the rams made a call in january like
they kicked the tires in january before
they made the deal with matthew stafford
yeah it does feel like teams got
impatient though even you could even say
san francisco got impatient by trading
up
when they did to give up what they did i
don't think atlanta was going to draft
trey lance we know cincinnati was not
going to draft trey lance did you have
to get to three
i know that they'll come out and say we
needed to get to three so we could
control the process so that we could
put these guys through all the tests and
everything i still think they overpaid
great to visit with you matt thanks for
joining us and uh we'll stay in touch
sounds great dan have a good day that's
matt miller espn draft contributor
i like when we have guests on and they
agree with me
yeah if i'm the niners and i could trade
three first
and i could trade a third round pick and
i could get aaron rodgers
yes absolutely
rogers would want to go now you got to
convince the packers that
hey you can make aaron the bad guy but
you got to trade him
you know if you want public sentiment on
your side you can do that
now you just have to be sold on jordan
love being your future
because that's what this is all going to
come back to